[Music]
so will smith has broken his silence and
has come out apologizing to chris rock
formally in a video that he uploaded to
youtube i'm a big fan oh uh
didn't that look like a forced apology
though you think so well there were
snippets of it yeah i saw some clips on
ig but i don't know if i didn't see it
at all can we can we watch it right now
let's watch it okay
let's see say we all think together as a
group unless he's singing i'm sorry so
sorry like it doesn't it's not it's not
a real apology okay all right
i like that it's his video here really
though oh it's all sparkling
oh wow it feels a little cloudy because
of that
he needs to just do it on a [ __ ] web
like like a phone why didn't you
apologize to chris in your acceptance
speech oh he's responding commenters
i was fogged out by that point
that's honest it's it's it's it's all
fuzzy i've reached out to
chris um
and the mesh the message that came back
is that
he's not ready to talk
and when he is
he will
reach out
um
so i will i will say to you
chris i
apologize
to you
uh my behavior
was
unacceptable
and i'm here
whenever you're ready to talk um
okay so thoughts about that real quick
we have to react to it we can just play
it okay
uh i have a lot of thoughts so one it's
like
it sounds kind of man it's it's so many
layers it sounds forced to me it feels
weird because um so like what the first
layer is it doesn't sound authentic like
you're having an actual conversation but
then the second layer to that i
understand that because he probably has
a legal team so he can't
self-incriminate himself where chris can
push it even further so he can't say i'm
sorry for slapping you bro that's [ __ ]
up he has to say my behavior is
unacceptable you know it's like it's
like you got lawyers like do you think
he doesn't sound like himself it's
definitely not himself he just sounds
kind of will smith though right yeah but
the words the words he used like bro if
i go like if i pour water on him i'm
like
um
nick i'm so sorry that a beverage has
spilled
upon a pond5 upon thee
let's [ __ ] said bye like why are
you [ __ ] saying [ __ ] like that you
know how about you [ __ ] spill coffee
on you you know it doesn't sound real
but i also understand
like in a game of [ __ ] where everyone
has hell of money you don't want to
press charges everyone got to bring the
whole legal team into that [ __ ] i don't
know
okay that's what i think thoughts
anybody else thoughts i don't know it's
hard when you it's hard to have a real
legit apology when there's that much
pre-production put into it yeah yeah
there's a lot of lights in there for
sure and there's like 300. 300 kilo
floors how are you going to do that be
like oh like it's not a rehearsed thing
it's my genuine apology but yet you had
a rehearsal probably for sure you got to
stand and do the camera blogging for you
for this [ __ ] that's like the people on
[ __ ] instagram i was like hold on let
me get the right angle
and you got a guy going like i'm getting
sag rates for this one
exactly yeah
i don't know i i give it a little bit of
the benefit of the doubt still i mean i
just feel like that's part of the world
that we live in like that's just how
[ __ ] gets done you know what i mean if
you put on a cell phone then you're
gonna get scrutinized for like not
taking the time to like thank you
so so far it feels very will smith it's
not like snoop dogg did it and then
comes on and it's like i don't spilled
what you know what i mean like this is
what will smith does he doesn't [ __ ]
cuss in his raps like he's just that
very pc kind of person yeah it feels
like will smith he's doing a giant
apology at the end of the day for a slap
you know what i mean like it's already
judgment without watching the whole
video like a weirdo nah i don't i don't
think i don't think what he's saying
matched a nationally televised this
you know what i mean yeah but there's
also been no precedent i'm like if this
[ __ ] was like on his knees i'm
[ __ ] sorry to the [ __ ] world yeah
he don't seem to watch this i can't beat
the [ __ ] out of someone and be like my
apologies
it doesn't [ __ ] match dude gets food
on the corner of his mouth that's a
[ __ ] problem apologize to
chris's mother i saw an interview that
chris's mother did
and you know that was one of the things
about that moment i just didn't realize
and you know i wasn't thinking but how
many people got hurt
in that moment
so i want to apologize to chris's mother
my father went through his whole family
chris's family uh specifically tony rock
you know we had a great relationship
you know tony rock was my man why just
slap his brother there and uh this is
this is probably irreparable
um
i spent the last
three months
replaying
and
understanding the nuances and and the
complexities of what happened i don't
like this is so real
it's you you feel it's real
no no so real in terms of you know when
you're making it too real it's like dude
it's a [ __ ] slap honestly personally
it's like will can you just get on tv
and chris can you come just slap him
twice on national television and then we
just call it over and worry about some
real [ __ ] my whole thing is that it is
just a slap yeah that sounds like
[ __ ] he acted like chris rock can't
reproduce anymore yeah yeah yeah that's
what he can't do that's what i'm saying
it was just a slap it's too serious so
that's that's the uh third layer that i
that for me it's like um what i think
he's really revealing
is like man like [ __ ] jada has her
hand up my [ __ ] ass and in that
moment when i first laughed because i
thought that was a hilarious joke when i
looked over at her face and her
disappointment in me i just couldn't
take it anymore and my [ __ ] marriage
is like about to fall apart at any
moment it's about to be a public
catastrophe so what do i do what do i do
what do i do and the [ __ ] cool the
cool chill will smith that we know it
[ __ ] everything blew up you know it's
like you see the smoothest dude in the
[ __ ] world act in the most awkward
erratic way and i think that's him
trying that's why he's saying nuances
and i was [ __ ] [ __ ] he's trying
to like have a big enough explanation to
explain all the little things that we've
all saw that happened you think he's the
smoothest dude in the [ __ ] world yeah
before he's pretty smooth rep wise yeah
are you not a fan of will smith very
very clean you know what i mean it's
like he's he's just that dude i saw wawa
west i was excited
when i was a child i was excited i was
too i got my whole [ __ ] family to go
i was so excited about it
and then i saw that [ __ ] movie so
yeah he i think he betrayed me a little
bit in that when i was when i was very
young i would rather have that just get
sued pay like some hefty fun everybody
moves on with their lives because like
that should just happen sometimes you
know what i mean i want him to just
submit the truth i want him to go i will
never be as gangsta as tupac and jada
always makes me feel like a little [ __ ]
because i'm always compared to tupac if
he said some [ __ ] like that i'm like
dude i [ __ ] know where that slap came
from he goes and i did the most
gangsterous [ __ ] i thought i could do
let's see if he goes there in that
moment
um
and
i'm not gonna try to unpack all of that
right now but i can say to
all of you there is no
part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to
behave
in that moment
there's no part of me that thinks that's
the optimal way
to
handle
a feeling of disrespect or or insults
[Music]
after jada rolled her eyes did she tell
you to do something oh yeah that's what
we want to know
um
it's like
you know i'm i made a choice
on my own
from my own experiences from
my
history with chris jada had nothing to
do with it
i'm sorry babe
um
i would say sorry to my my kids and
my family
for the heat that i brought
on all of us
um to all my damn guys
what do you mean by this is a history
with chris like he's been he's been
pissed at him before he didn't elaborate
i think it's uh based on the the jokes
that chris rock
i wonder if he's like warned him in the
past like bro stop joking about this
[ __ ] it's also like hey dude they're
punching up you know you guys are
[ __ ] the smiths you know it's not
that big of a deal jay to pick it she'll
be fine you know if if chris rock tells
a joke about her
that at that awards show i mean they say
i mean she's nairobi what does she have
to wear oh she's not [ __ ] nairobi she
got the [ __ ] coolest hairstyle in the
matrix
in the most recent yeah with terrible
yeah that was really really really
i thought it was a wonderful movie you
guys have bad tastes do you swear i'm
disgusted by that comment you really
liked it
you know what
all right next part
oh
it really breaks my heart to have stolen
and and harnessed tarnished your moment
um
i can still see
quest loves while he's playing the drums
i [ __ ] love wait wait wait i want to
keep watching the rest well the dancer's
over the dancers had enough
just tap it out yeah
this is comedy to me because when i when
he says quest love i see chris love like
doing this with a [ __ ] like with that
frog home in this area he's like that
cuz that was his award right the [ __ ]
yeah like i said i [ __ ] love will
smith i just don't like him like this is
all or in this moment hey maybe that's
the real hidden
ward and
you know
it's like i'm um
i'm sorry really is it sufficient
i think it is it was what would you say
to the people who looked up to you
before the slap i like them more people
who expressed
them down a little bit
um
so there's two things one
um
disappointing people is my central
trauma
um i hate
when
i let people down um so
it
it hurts
uh it hurts me psychologically and
emotionally to know i didn't live up to
uh people's
image and impression of me so this is
what he's imagining right we're all like
this when we see will smith before the
right and then will smith smacks chris
rock and then we're all like
for the people that grew up on him
that is what they feel though yeah it's
like a smaller version of like bill
cosby like the squeaky clean person and
then you destroy his own image yeah but
that's what i'm saying that happens in
the world though like bill cosby's
happening that's why i look at this and
i'm like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah bill cosby's happen a lot
more than they need to yeah but we're we
understand that people aren't just like
one
way like you know like there's so many
people out there that are like shocked
when they go oh my god that politician
is actually shady
like yeah there's so many people
actually that that they take whatever
they see that's branded on the surface
level and that's what they believe and
their whole world gets shattered when
someone kind of violates that when we
know that will smith is a human [ __ ]
being with he's gonna make mistakes
and i love that moment where he slapped
the dude i mean he slapped chris it was
like a moment of he's a human being
because i was in disbelief that that was
actually real i thought it was like
constructed totally i thought it was
like a marketing ploy because of his
squeaky clean image and why would he
ruin that for something like this i
thought he was up to something else
because he wouldn't be impulsive that's
cause that's the crazy part where it's
like bill cosby isn't like
oh [ __ ] it's the [ __ ] grammy's
camera you see this
oh sure right that's the crazy part his
choice
to choose that moment on the most
televised show once a year annual thing
to do that i think that's the crazy part
that that is the question what compelled
it like if you slap chris
chris rock in the green room different
story right he's being human right but
him on
the most like uh anticipated show of
that year at that time it's crazy so
you're saying that it's so out that's
also his whole life like going to events
like that he does that every it's normal
for him we're like oh my god national tv
like this [ __ ] is national tv
yeah i'm saying so it's like that's my
whole life i just wish that he [ __ ]
brought the noise with like hey dude you
guys know how many characters i've
played over the years right they're all
living inside of me he's like that
wasn't will smith that was my [ __ ]
lowry
if he did that
respect i understand that he's like i
almost pulled out muhammad ali for a
second yeah he's like sometimes they
just come through i don't know what the
[ __ ] to do about it but then when you
have hollow words that's the that's the
part i'm like why'd you even make this
video
you know what i mean i still blame jada
dude
i'd rather see him on mike tyson's
podcast right or mike tyson's like
talking about it i tell him what the
[ __ ] is the real thing you know
and then if he really breaks down
because i feel like mike tyson's the
person like no one's done more dirt than
him yeah and then he's like tell him
what the [ __ ] is going on whatever and
then if mil smith really like poured it
all out on me that's way dopamine she's
already had to go through with the whole
red table thing with the august august
what you know what i mean yeah but he
can't do that that's why it seems like
there should be more there like what you
just said with the red table stuff but
then his apology doesn't seem like it's
tethered to any of that when it everyone
watching is like dude because the red
table is a the bounce pass right yeah
the oscars is an alley-oop
he caught it and he just rolls it on the
ground
like everyone's waiting for this big
and he just like
like everyone made all this crazy ass
play and he's like oh i [ __ ] wanted
him to say like hey dude i'm so pissed
about the table talk and all that [ __ ]
and like that's why i did this [ __ ]
whatever it is it needs to feel real and
i'm left with more questions yeah not
some larry h parker written script
perry h parker we'll fight for you it's
the most hollow legal [ __ ] i don't know
again yeah i'm still more of the benefit
to be honest i just can't wait until
everybody doesn't give a [ __ ] and then
he just makes another couple million
dollars on his next inevitable yeah it's
inevitable it's gonna happen [ __ ]
cares at this point well this it was
really entertaining when it happened
you're very very entertaining for us to
talk about it but like this is another
one of those moments where it's like
like we talked about yesterday really
how about like where's the list
where is the [ __ ] the million things
more important the main thing is that
even though it's just a slap what it is
it's just like janet jackson has just a
tit but it's not just a tip because
that's the first time that's ever
happened in this actual situation like
it's very like specific thing right and
as will smith like you know you're about
to do something that's never been
[ __ ] done so it's not like you just
stalk the guy it's like you're about to
be the first of this thing
and that's gonna be referenced forever
in a way like that kind of changed how
like if you're a kid and that's the
first time you ever saw these awards
you're always gonna think it's
associated with the awards forever dude
when i saw jan jackson's titty
i cried so hard and my mom had to
explain to me what titties was
a disappointment i was so disappointed
in janet you know she was she was my
favorite artist look at how that like
there's documentaries still being made
about that
that's crazy and now it's delving into
how it affected uh justin
disproportionately to janet it's like
all this extra [ __ ] when you think oh
someone apologizes over it's like bro
maybe this isn't the last we see this
either yeah because it propelled
justin's career where it destroyed janet
what can we finish it though because
because i want to see what the hell
like i'm just i'm just curious now um
i i feel like he hasn't said anything
anything worthy
yet i mean it's basically done the video
is basically i mean the apology could be
substituted for so many apologies of
this kind he says something to the to
the tune at the end of like you know
like hopefully down the line to my fans
or whatever like you can you know we'll
be friends again if you if you you know
are willing or whatever
i was waiting for like
at the last minute he goes
but damn i'll never be as strong as
tupac
no at the end he goes watch bright two
on
netflix it's coming out later this year
just i mean if you want joe we can do
that um
might as well we already got this far
let me just finish it just be a 20
minute video without being ashamed of
myself
right i'm human
and
i made
a mistake
and
i'm trying not to think of myself as a
piece of [ __ ]
um
it was confusing i know it was
shocking
um
but i i promise you
i am
uh deeply devoted and committed to
putting light and love and joy
into the world and
you know then why did you make men in
black three
if you if you're hanging on i promise
we'll be able to be friends again we're
gonna bring kay back
he's in that no
running back three he's a member yeah he
is either bringing kate back from the
post office yeah what are you doing oh
[ __ ] you never seen that [ __ ] oh we're
talking about the most recent one the
women in black the women one
international
uh chris hemsworth or something yeah
doesn't that one like super suck it does
super it's still pretty good it's
incredible actually that piece of [ __ ]
line was the most real thing everything
else was a fouchy speech i just don't
wanna like him man like he just dances
around [ __ ] you know you don't want to
like no i still want to like i want to
like
because i love him that's why i think i
was like oh cool he'll make it right and
then i'm like oh that didn't make it
right i want to like him so bad i
believe jada pickett is on the other
side of the camera and she's like
[ __ ] say these goddamn words i think
she's just sugar and sugar
i think it'd be sick if
if james avery was still around if they
had him on the opposite side going what
were you thinking yeah yeah that would
make me feel good dude uncle phil but
then but then he looks at me he's like
how come you don't love me
or or he hugs you jada's like i never
loved you because of tupac
or he hugs him after the video and he's
like now that was acting
will like accidentally says tupac he's
like only god can just [ __ ] god damn it
he's like he doesn't want to say tupac
lyrics instead of uncle phil we should
have jeffrey
oh my god
master williams
how dare you it's still it still holds
up still good it's a good show
you gotta stick with them during the
highs and lows y'all come on that's why
i still listen to r kelly dude i still
think i still think even even with the
even with the negativity this is still a
high
[Music]
you